they call this the wooden house district
of Helsinki these beauties were built
back in the early 1900s so that the
workers of Finland could have nice
places to live and nice gardens to tend
their symbolic of Finland's famed social
support system that has made Finns some
of the happiest people on earth bless
you Finland and your wheelbarrow Gardens
of course progress often has its own
plans the workers here for example have
been replaced by artsy hipsters seeking
a trendy neighborhood and soon enough
workers and hipsters all over the world
might be replaced by robots that don't
care about social systems or pretty
Gardens at all
hello robot overlords here at Helsinki's
most scenic garbage dump are some
hard-working robotic arms from a company
called Zen robotics the Zen part
obviously being some bizarre marketing
ploy because there's nothing calming
about these things their mission is to
divvy up industrial trash sorting things
like wood and metal into their own piles
how do you get the robot to see you know
that it's not wood that it's a piece of
steel a plastic bag all this stuff is so
amorphous and effort be your cameras we
use metal detectors we use 3d sends us
and we used all the near infrared
sensors say AI is able and to predict
okay what kind of material we try to
understand how is a human operator
sorting waste and he is not picking it
and putting it here it picks and throws
yeah and we simulated the same movement
so our robot opens equipment lets the
object fly and what do we know about how
accurate the robots are depending on the
different kind of ways we can go to a
purity up to ninety percent here we go
take a closer look yes
so the waste comes up it goes on this
conveyor belt and then this is where
it's getting spin and then in this
moment where it's getting scanned it's
telling the robots down the line there's
gonna be an object coming and then I
want you to grab yes and then the arms
start to go to work
yes the robot gets to pick which ways
and to throw it in which spin I mean
it's a really good job today of picking
up these objects that are such different
sizes you can believe that are many men
hours invested to really develop a
gripper what is able to grip total
different kind of sizes shades and I
think that is one of the biggest
challenges
Zen robotics recently put its robots to
work right here in the heart of Silicon
Valley at this massive garbage
processing facility in San Jose
artificial intelligence and trash
commingling and harmony just the way
nature intended
back in Finland I took a drive from the
dump to ESPO
it's a city about 25 minutes outside of
Helsinki that is something of a tech
suburb Nokia's once glorious
headquarters are here and so to our it's
more sedate current headquarters and the
Angry Birds are here too but I have not
come to a spa for disgruntled birds or
airborne pigs I have come to see some
satellites this is the headquarters of
ëyesí it's one of a handful of startups
that have built small satellites that
take constant pictures of what's
happening on earth how many satellites
have you guys put up today the
commercial constellation that we operate
right now is three solo three satellites
and then your satellites their
mini-fridge yeah and then you also want
to try and surround the earth with with
dozens hundreds of these things right
yeah so we really want to make the
system that allows you to sort of
reliably and accurately and sort of
objectively see everything at the whole
times it's almost like you know having a
sort of a MRI scan for the earth
I sigh satellites travel from pole to
pole every 45 minutes rather than
cameras their three swell SATs use
something called synthetic aperture
radar or SAR to pound the earth with
microwave signals from low-earth orbit
they then used signals that are
reflected back from the earth to build
images of the surface
unlike cameras SAR can see through the
cloudiest of days in the darkest of
nights ice I combined this radar
technology with advanced image
processing and computer vision software
to create highly detailed pictures to a
peek at some of these images and walk
through kind of what you guys do so this
was an example of the hurricane durian
in in Bahamas
we were able to image this exactly when
the hurricane was on top of the island
this is the island as it normally is
then in in the afterwards the land
border used to be here and I think
here's a really dramatic thing is that
all of these red dots are you know
buildings you know fully submerged this
is exactly you know what becomes a sort
of insurance information yes you have
proof but others the flooded and yeah
yeah and I'd proof is one thing and then
of course you just ability to react it
like now you know what if you could
trigger the payment to these these guys
automatically so that like the people
get to rebuild their lives and so forth
yeah yeah now here we're looking at
large tanker the grace one it relates to
the sanctions to Iran it became this big
story when it was impounded in Gibraltar
when it was said that it was headed
towards Syria with a tank full of
Iranian oil this is an image from a
while back where we're able to see the
grace one ship here in the Iranian
shores okay in in January so maybe the
US knows where this tanker is the NSA
knows the CIA and they can choose to
make public what they want but basically
with you guys I mean there's a
democratization to all this where anyone
who's willing to pay for your imagery
you know yeah it's not just in the hands
of these few governments now it's like
everybody good yeah can know what's
going on yeah I think I think that's you
know part of the part of the big story
here in the case of this tanker like
what was really interesting is what was
it full or was not full powerful was it
if it's full of oil it's down in the
water and you're getting something on
yeah just the depth from like a shadow
off the water or something yeah and this
is a mine it's an open pit mine
so you know this is like the more
mundane use case here is just that you
monitor the progress of the mining
activity but of course you know the
safety of is there some display
ventilation you're likely to cause
landslides or is there some underground
mining that is likely to cause collapses
when it started in 2014 ice I was the
very first company to build a commercial
satellite in Finland since then it's
raised more than 65 million dollars from
investors and plans to launch a
constellation of 18 small satellites in
the next couple of years right now we're
sort of fully booked with customers so
there would be some governments there
there would be some insurance some
finance I mean there's like a ton of
positive use cases all the stuff I do
think some people though would be
creeped out a bit right about this
all-seeing eye that is keeping track of
what people are doing I think you know
as far as sort of like a sort of
creepiness on us or personal level I
think a lot of the the sort of mobile
phones you know internet you know your
google type services like they tend to
track you to much higher precision than
we ever are so like you know we would
never really be in the business of
identifying humans like you know we
don't image faces or like the resolution
is way lower than that for us it's about
objectivity of being able to provide as
neutral source of information as
possible
[Music]
hey I robots and super fancy satellites
are all well and good
probably but no visit to Finland would
be complete without exploring its oldest
and most famous tech the sauna or as
they say it hear the sound
and since Finland is a tiny place full
of accommodating people I was able to
find not just a sauna but the sauna and
not just any sauna companion but the
sauna companion Finland's most famous
actor
yes but back on him along with having an
outstanding 6-pack jasper owns this
beauty he joined me at about 11:00 p.m.
to teach me the art of the sauna and
what it means to the Finnish people when
you walk into a sauna you're stripped
down from your clothes you're stripped
down from all the titles your wealth you
leave your wallet outside and it's just
a bunch of people at their most bare
state of being and it's really hard to
not be honest when you're so exposed and
so bare so this is a pretty common thing
is to take over here and hash things out
yeah sauna is the only word from Finnish
language to travel to other languages as
a as a common word to use and and saunas
are more common in Finn it's more common
to own a sauna that it is to own a car
okay which means every single person has
a song yeah
everybody has these ciders but the ones
here are very traditional and well you
know what what is the classic Finnish
sauna the real song it would always be a
would heat it would heat it sauna
because the burning of the wood gives it
gives the other song nights it's this
very distinct flavor or this load load
of the word means like the spirit of the
sauna I feel when you throw water on to
the sauna heaters rocks
that's load and you just get much better
load when you are heat it with wood
perhaps unimpressed by my grasp of the
Finnish language Gasper decided it was a
good idea to complete the sauna
experience by subjecting me to a
ritualized form of icy torture down to
our necks and then we take a few deep
kind of just easy breaths
try not to hyperventilate all right
let's see now you start feeling this on
tingling able to breathe now and you
don't feel cold right no good actually
yes once you do it a few times first you
get used to it yeah and then you get
addicted to it so how many times would
you do that during the course of a saw
that session I usually do it four times
back and forth okay so sauna is when the
sauna swim and then you end it would be
a with the swim I often say that sauna
is like the church for a normal average
Finn he or she goes to the sauna you're
in silence and you sweat out the daily
sorrows both mentally and physically
there's something church like sadly I
think our version is like football game
is over
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you